hallo herzlich willkommen in meine
torten welt diese keksdosen hier habe
ich aus dem gleichen hotel attac gemacht
wie die valentinstags kekse und wenn ihr
wissen wollt wie ihr die selber machen
könnt dann bleibt jetzt dran
den teig habe ich dieses mal schon
vorbereitet das rezept kennt ihr hier
und jetzt wollt ihr denn einfach ganz
normal aus wie bei den anderen keksen
und dann steht ihr einfach plätzchen aus
die form ist euch überlassen ich mache
jetzt noch wann dienstag steaks sind
deswegen die herzform
ihr könnt die genauso gut rechteckig
oder rund ausstechen
und dann nehmt ihr es sich hier runter
und setzt sie auf ein backblech
wenn ihr es dann soweit habt werden die
hexe wieder bei 200 grad etwa vier bis
sechs minuten gebacken und danach geht
es sofort weiter
wenn sie dann aus dem ofen raus sind
sehen sie so aus
dann müsst ihr diese fahrt weiter
verarbeiten und zwar kommt jetzt noch
das loch in die mitte und staat zu nehmt
ihr euch einen kleineren ausstechen
schaut einfach welcher am besten passt
wie sieht's mit dem das müsst ihr machen
solange sie noch heiß sind und ihr
braucht später dann immer ein zwei
komplette kekse und zwei mit löchern für
eine keksdose
um ihr seht ich auf die bisserl zu engen
aufs blech gesetzt also damit ein
bisschen aufpassen und genug abstand
lassen und es lass dir so komplett
auskühlen
ich habe jetzt in der zwischenzeit reihe
leistung eingestellt dass das zeug dazu
findet er aufwind video was ich vorher
gemacht hatte und jetzt nehmt ihr euch
die plätzchen und nimmt vorsichtig hier
das innere raus wenn es nicht so gut
geht vielleicht noch mal mit dem fix
ausstecher und dann vorsichtig heraus
das macht er aber am besten wenn sie
noch was sind meine situation hart ich
hab's vergessen vorher
jetzt setzt ihr immer die plätzchen
zusammen habe sich das gleiche prinzip
wie bei den kürbis keksen einfach hier
etwas rising drauf
dann ein keks dann noch mal von diesen
racing und stand der zweite keks und das
hier später der deckel der wird nicht
geklebt und so macht ihr besitzt mit
allen keksen
jetzt werden einfach noch die deckel
dekoriert und dann sind die keks boxen
auch schon fertig
eure keksdosen die sind dann fertig dann
können diese einfach mit flüssigkeiten
füllen oder was auch immer ihr wollt und
so lasse ich sie dann einfach in einer
keksdose oder können sie ganz schön
verpacken und dann verschenken
ich hoffe die kleine idee hat euch
gefallen und ich freue mich schon aufs
nächste mal tschüss